this is a prince who spent his entire
life in his brother's shadow and I think
in Megan he's found a new confidence and
wants to move on and be his own person
but inevitably it's going to mean that
we see lesser than working together and
more of them striking out independently
like as independently as moving to
Africa that's the rumor floating around
about the Duke and Duchess of Sussex
the royal couple just recently moved out
of Tenzing Tempest and into Frogmore
cottage this is a very deliberate move
on the Sussex is part
Harry's very keen for baby Sussex to be
brought up in the countryside but he's
also keen to strike out on his own but
now reports have surfaced claiming that
Harry and Megan will be moving again
across the world Buckingham Palace
released a statement on Monday to
address the gossip writing any future
plans for the Duke and Duchess of Sussex
are speculative at this stage no
decision has been taken about future
roles hmm that isn't exactly a denial
now a source tells ET the potential
plans to relocate to Africa for about
two to six months are in the quote
beginning stages adding that the new
assignment would be a way to gain
popularity in a Commonwealth country the
source explained too that the move
wouldn't happen before 2020 adding it
would be quote an opportunity for them
to work in their already established
humanitarian roles the idea is it's
really a step beyond the traditional
royal visit an opportunity to have some
roots and time in a place so that they
can focus more in depth and interact in
the community as UK ambassadors we're a
fantastic team we know we land and we
hope to overtime try and have as much
impact for the things that we care about
as much a move would also mean that the
two would be far away from Harry's older
brother Prince William and his wife Kate
Middleton whom they have been seemingly
more distant with over the past few
months the palace have tried to knock
these rumours of attention between the
four Royals on the head and it does seem
to be the case that perhaps they they
don't all get along as well as we
thought
they might do but our source says not to
read into it quote any potential move
has absolutely nothing to do with any
perceived rift between William and Harry
William is fully supportive for now
Megan and Harry are focusing on the
birth of baby Sussex who according to a
royal source is do quote any day now
they're super excited about the spring
birth of their baby and I'm told that
she's upbeat and that she's happy
Megan's mom Doria Ragland arrived in
London over the weekend in anticipation
of the royal baby's arrival a source
recently told ET Megan is enjoying her
pregnancy adding quote it is such a
happy and exciting time for Megan she is
looking forward to becoming a mother
[Music]